matt harvey's been their second most
consistent starting pitcher
and it's a special day for him as he
goes back to city field yeah a very
emotional day i think the first inning
is the most important for harvey can he
control his emotions a little bit and
then just kind of settle in
to a place where he had so much success
where he started an all-star game where
he pitched in the world series
where you return to where you started
your big league career it's always
special he's back
where it all began for matt harvey some
years ago that's this year with taiwan
walker on the mound
are five and one his era is 2.38 and
he's only allowed one home run
and 34 innings pitched and
walker strikes him out with a fast ball
and that's taiwan's afternoon begins
with a k
here's austin hayes who flies one out to
left center field dominic smith back in
the gap with pilar on the warning track
pillar jumps makes the catch
and avoids a collision with dom at the
same time
quite a play by pilar up against the
wall
with dom going for the ball as well and
all's well that ends with
mancini first pitch swinging drive down
the right field line
off the top of the wall conforto plays
it off the wall mancini
into second and he's safe on a close
play
[Applause]
and he chops one off the plate right
back to walker
and that retires the side a double in
one left mets come to bat against matt
harvey when we come back
they remember the dark knights
contributions to the met so he gets
welcomed back by met fans
matt harvey takes them out this time
pitching for the orioles
happy harvey day the 1-0 there's his
swing
fly ball right field hayes coming in
tells everyone he's got it and he puts
it away one gun
hit hard down to first mancini gloves it
will take it himself
two down
bounced to second ruiz up with it and
harvey
first inning back no butterflies he gets
him one two three
orioles coming to bat no score
and there's ball four so a four pitch
walk two orioles on
two down two on and the pitcher matt
harvey
gets a nice warm ovation from the met
fans
they remember what he did for their team
in their town
[Applause]
and walker picks off the outside corner
and takes care of harvey for his second
strikeout
and works around a couple of walks in
the second no score
[Applause]
that's a fair ball off the bat of alonso
down the line he'll take the turn he's
going to try for two
hayes recovers makes the throw on target
but not in time
and pete hangs on to the bag with an
opposite field double
that's lying to the center field a base
hit for dom alonso had to hold off he'll
go to third and stop there
so the mets are first and third first
and third and nobody out for kevin
pillar who had two hits last night
scored the tying run in the night then
he hits one in the air to deep left
center field back goes mullins to the
warning track back at the wall
he can't make the catch it bounces away
alonso is in
being waved home as smith he'll score
pillar dives into third base with a two
run triple
and the mitts have a two nothing lead
now a runner at third nobody out
in field in for jose perazzi grabs one
in the hole that's a base hit and
that'll bring in pilar
with the third run of the inning with
the infield in
peraza making just his second start as a
met finds a hole
the mets with four straight hits against
matt harvey and they lead three nothing
bounce to short galvez big play did he
get him oh what a play
freddy galvez in the hole
diving and throwing in the same motion
one down
and he misses on the bun attempt out on
strikes is taiwan walker two down
full count pitch on the way swung on and
missed so
vr down on strikes true in all sports
roy was an injury away that's driven to
right center overcomes conforto to dive
and he made the catch oh wow
michael conforto continues to
distinguish himself with the glove
another fantastic play
by conforto
strike three called and mancini is
caught looking
walker has his third strike adam with
help from conforto he's got a one two
three inning
that's lying down the right field line
andorra's got a base hit chased by hayes
and he'll hold the door to a single
[Applause]
taking the other way and dom's got to
hit and that'll bring lindor around
so the stolen base produces a run dom
smith is two for two in the mets of a
four nothing lead
well they're in prince nobody wants to
look swinging to miss at the curve ball
and walker has a strikeout
that's his fourth of the day as he gets
galvey's
michael franco hammers one down to third
vr makes the play and it's a one two
three inning
for taiwan walker in the fourth it's got
three in the second
one in the third and down goes peraza
strike three
says i'm pitching pretty good maybe i'll
just give up on the hitting part yeah
strike three
what was that good night everybody oh
big fella at least take a hack at it
and he loops one into center field and
that's going to fall for a base hit
so the mets have their seventh hit
against harvey a leadoff single for vr
in the fifth
he's running cisco with the sidearm
throw
no chance to get vr
up the middle a base hit for conforto
and that'll bring home
vr so the mets cash another stolen base
conferta with the rbi single to make it
five-nothing new york
has not been matt harvey's day and
disappointing for matt harvey
as he returns to city field mets lead
the orioles five nothing we've got a
pitching change
and dumb cracks one down the right field
line and that'll go to the corner for an
extra base hit
conforto is in alonso will be held at
third dom smith is three for
three his second rbi of the day this one
a one scoring double
and it's six nothing new york
carrazza pulls one down a third off the
glove of franco recovered by galves but
a run comes home
and it's seven to nothing and peraza's
excellent day continues that time with
the pinball
shot
mullins center field pilar coming
in and it falls in for a base hit
a little roller up the third baseline
walker fires wide of the bag and trey
mancini's got himself an infield hit
[Applause]
grounded down to third a chance for two
vr with the step and fire for the 5-5-3
double play
that retires the side it went out to the
warning track and left field is last at
that
hit hard there's a base hit
ruiz slaps it into center and the
orioles have runners on the corners
bounced down to first alonzo
steps on the bag orioles get their first
run
the shout out no longer
jam shot there tough play here spin on
that thing no way austin hayes gets down
the line for an infield base hit so
maybe that makes up for
those other two yeah into the funny game
3-2 pitch down low and now they're
loaded two walks and an infield hit
so here's franco with the bases loaded
and two down
line to short and caught by peraza
playing
in the shift another bullet another play
by a midfielder peraza timed his lead
perfectly
and good to see drew smith back on the
mound for new york yeah only pitched
seven
innings uh last season
again the one two he struck him out and
the ball game is over
drew smith returns to the big leagues
with a one two three ninth taiwan walker
with seven more terrific
innings mets play some outstanding
defense and the mets have now won
seven straight sweeping a pair from the
orioles
winning today seven to one